this is the Costa Dorada on the
Mediterranean coast of Spain many
Spaniards and foreigners have bought
holiday homes here the construction
crane in the center of Cumbria's has
stood unused for a long time a relic of
the property bubble but things are
picking up again on the Spanish property
market esta Visayas works for a
construction company in companies he's
showing to real estate agents some
condominiums at the moment he says
foreign has a back in a buying mood and
it's about time too this complex has
been half empty for more than five years
despite the big pool
the designers asked our we've been
steadily reducing the price it's down
50% now there's just no demand but we
are noticing and improve it if things
carry on this way
we'll probably raise the prices a little
therapist I love fun but the Realtors
aren't thrilled despite the heated
indoor pool and fitness centers yelling
they're gross and her Spanish business
partner focus on Russian customers and
they want a little more than a shared
sauna a villa for example they're going
cheap at the moment at 380 thousand
euros this recently built property costs
a third of what it did before the crisis
and that is attracting attention the
number of inquiries from Russia has
doubled since the start of the year
interest is growing and sales are
improving people were holding back and
waiting for prices to fall now most of
them realize that they have bottomed out
this is the time now to make a good deal
there's plenty of Sun and the Seas at
the end of the road
Cumbres has a lot that nervosa Pierce
does not and the Spanish government has
added incentives anyone who buys
property worth 160 thousand or more
receives a residence permit and that
means it's worth bringing the Porsche
over from Russia to just a few steps
down the road 24 unfinished houses stand
as a monument to the burst property
bubble the shell of an unfinished
construction project is something like a
national symbol of Spain at the moment
many firms have had their property
seized by creditors as a result Spanish
banks probably owned more abandoned
constructions than anyone else in the
world
but true to their profession the real
estate agents are optimistic they
believe the cement mixers will soon be
turning here again the market is moving
again sales are pretty good after all
the years of crisis so construction
companies need the courage to start
building again and the bank should be
more flexible customers are returning
sales rose by 20 percent across the
country last year the main movement
happened in coastal regions but no
worries there's enough left for everyone
there are an estimated 800,000 empty
properties in Spain and there's plenty
of choice in companies there are some
interesting things on offer at the
marina - at least for those with the
necessary cash